ils ont 12 milles et 6000 abonnés chacun
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi poker room
manif je m'excuse par avance pour la
casquette parce que de sousse passé un
truc un petit peu particulier je vous en
parle très bientôt dans mon blogue au
japon y arriver rapidement mais n'en
veut pas et d'un truc n'est ce pas
samedi sur twitter on m'a parlé d'une
émission télé qui parle de moi et de
squeeze j'en ai parlé sur instagram
peut-être vous avez déjà vu on va
revenir ensemble à dessus parce que je
pense que c'est important
remettons les choses dans leur contexte
et les matins est une émission qui
existe depuis nous le année sur france
télé france 2 en l'occurrence et c'est
une émission qui s'adresse aux gens qui
se lèvent plus tôt et j'imagine les
personnes plutôt âgées
jusque là tout va bien aucun problème
dans cette émission il décide de parler
deux jeux vidéo l'a déjà normalement si
vous êtes un peu expérimenté avec les
télévisions françaises ça commence à
sentir un peu à grenews ces partis
regardons l'extrait ensemble non
d'accord donc l'émission de vendredi
marche et l'émission de samedi a tout
simplement été supprimé
moi je suis à coeur du dimanche on va la
retrouver
[Musique]
j'ai retrouvé la vidéo france télé 06
priant 1
alors le jeu en ligne jean-louis serait
parti comme une véritable aujourd'hui
communes et des communautés monde et
c'est tout si internet évidemment via
internet de ces changements alors il
suffit de voir le phénomène des 8000
youtuber barre aujourd'hui les plus
riches les plus suivis au monde voilà
youtuber qu'est-ce qui est collé juste
après les plus riches
c'est même pas qu'est ce qu'ils font qui
sont-ils etc c'est d'abord qui sont les
plus riches
regardez d'autres interviews après et
vous allez voir qu'on n'est pas tous
égaux
voilà face aux bd poursuivons pas ce que
ça va être excellent par la suite c'est
son nez youtuber qui jouent en direct à
des jeux vidéo il se filme ils
commentent leur parti et ça ça s'appelle
le gaming al voici ce qu'est le gaming
est ce qu'ils vont dire après sa part
lors les stars les champions du genre en
france apple store en france vient et
squeeze c'est ce que vous voyez là je
découvre grâce à télématin que je suis
une star du gaming
certes j'ai eu une chaîne qui s'appelait
ciprian gaming mais malheureusement
n'est juste plus absolument tout le
monde sait que je suis une une bille en
jeu vidéo à moi je joue juste animal
crossing et à final fantasy c'est tout
là déjà c'est bon les erreurs
s'enchaînent mais ne se ressemblent pas
on arrive à quoi c'est le summum le
point culminant de cette émission est ce
que vous voyez là ils ont 12 milles et
6000 abonnés chacun
[Musique]
what ok ok ok on reprend un petit peu ça
me dérange pas se trompe sur des
chiffres pour moi en l'occurrence je
m'en fous c'est les gens disent ouais je
crois qu il a deux abonnés ça m'est égal
journaliste dit que avec squeeze on a
douze mille et 6000 abonnés ce qui pas
dégueu déjà franchement et plein de gens
qui rêveraient d'avoir autant d'abonnés
mais juste ça mon le sérieux porté aux
jeux vidéo et aux youtuber je ne suis
pas un youtuber réellement gaming quizy
quand même plus que moi il a une chaîne
switcher tout mais d'où viennent ces
chiffres je pense que ces 12 millions
pour la chaîne qui l'ont enlevé les
héros ou à la fin et je pense que pour
la chaîne de squeeze ils ont pris
peut-être bigorneaux et coquillages mais
en même temps il affiche vous l'avez vu
la chaîne squeeze gaming qui est sa
chaîne de live rien n'a de sens je
respecte énormément toutes les personnes
qui travaillent là dessus c'est juste
que ça témoigne quand même un petit bal
et kuzi sme ambiant dans les médias
c'est à dire oui bon millier des
millions ça va pas à tortiller du cul
mais un peu de sérieux ne mérite pas un
peu de sérieux de la danse qu'on vient
de voir on a un ultra combo
les chiffres sont faux on affiche
absolument n'importe quoi et par dessus
tout qui sont les plus riches ne parlons
que d'argent est pour moi très important
de s'être trompé sur des chiffres etc
c'est juste le sérieux qui est porté sur
voilà notre profession de youtube heures
car oui c'est un métier car on envie je
vais désormais vous parlez d'une
émission qui a fait grand bruit qui ont
accueilli pas mal de youtube heures donc
ça c'est pas mal mais dans quel but on
se le demande c'est l'émission salut les
terriens présentée et produite par
thierry ardisson on va revenir deux
mondes sur ce qui est dit 1 d'autres
durant cette interview que c'était en
2014 donc c'est plutôt jeunes tous
jeunes avaient commencé en 2007
au départ c'était 200 300 du maintenant
c'est des millions c'est des chiffres
hallucinants toutes vidéos confondues
vous cumulez 100 millions de
vu sur internet là on va parler d'un
petit truc en fait tous ces gens de télé
dans l'est dans la presse les médias
aiment bien nous présenter avec des
chiffres est derrière et la question de
l'argent qui arrive
elle est la regarde et attend millions
de vues la question de l'argent là
monsieur ardisson me présenta il me dit
ça fait 100 millions de vues tout le
monde applaudit que c'est et on voit sur
ma gueule vous cumulez 100 millions de
vues sur internet
sourire poli
en fait ces chiffres sont faux on n'est
pas aussi loin que la mascarade des
douze mille abonnés d'ailleurs un jour
j'espère arriver à 13000 abonnés un road
to 13000 abonnés commandes mais en fait
en 2014
j'étais pas du tout à 100 millions de
vues confondues on va vérifier c'est
tout de suite nous avons enfin les
chiffres
je sais qu'à peu près jusqu'à avril 2014
il n'y avait pas 100 millions de vues
mais 500 millions de tomates et je me
dis qu'il s'est pas trompé de chaîne et
je fais un peu appel à ma mémoire mais
il me semble avoir dit quelque chose là
dessus toi je tire cette tête de c'est
pas 100 millions de vues ça fait un peu
arrogant de venir corriger me sens que
j'ai dit genre c'est pas exactement ça
mais c'est pas grave
regardez comment ça se passe dans
l'émission 100 millions de vues sur
internet
sourire bizarre
je suis mort de rire comme le titre
était déjà créé en base 100 millions de
vues tu auras 100 millions du cip est ok
mais si tu as quelque chose à dire
okubo montage mon petit pote boom et
c'est la télévision ici on n'est pas là
pour rigoler faire des petites vidéos
sur votre talent à dans ta chambre
et on a parlé des chiffres vous savez ce
qui arrive derrière après à chaque vue
il ya une toute petite pub sage explique
la monétisation commentcamarche
monétisation parce qu'il n'a pas su quoi
cinq dix mille euros par mois quand même
non ebru quoi ça fait combien 5 10 ou
non de savoir d'ailleurs on va parler
essentiellement que de ça qu'est ce que
je réponds à ça de quoi vivre après
c'est le plus important pour moi surtout
l'indépendance en fait j'ai pas besoin
d'avoir vous n'êtes pas de chaîne
ouais voilà une chaîne quelqu'un qui me
dit faut faire si ça un autre angle je
fais ce que je veux
un matin je me lève j'écris quelque
chose ça me plaît ça ne plaît pas ces
propos sont tenus en 2014 mais ils sont
toujours vrai aujourd'hui effectivement
je peux gagner de l'argent mais je peux
surtout le réinvestir dans des projets
des courts métrages des sketches et
faire d'autres choses aussi à côté ça
m'ouvre des opportunités de faire de la
bande dessinée des jeux vidéo et plein
d'autres choses
vous verrez à plein d'autres actifs qui
vont arriver cette année année prochaine
vouloir ma fiche de paye et surtout ma
fiche d'imposition
ce n'a pas de sens si on de faire
redescendre un petit peu la pression
voilà parce que ce n'est pas terminé oh
non c'est en 2015 donc c'est un an après
thierry ardisson tout ça le grand
journal feu le grand jeu réclament une
structure malheureusement cette grande
émission sur canal + nous invite avec
lucas dans le cas d'une promotion bien
évidemment je pense que c'était pour le
squeeze game show juste prix game show
quelque chose comme ça et il nous invite
sur un plateau télé ce que la
malédiction se reproduit vous allez voir
quelque chose qui témoigne grandement de
l'intérêt et du sérieux porté aux
youtuber et à ce qu'on craignait
pourtant des questions aussi alors posé
je te laisse leur poser la première
question je serai
c'est ça ma vie je vais sur un plateau
télé on parle d'argent ou alors c'est
une enfant de 6 ans qui me posent des
questions mais est ce que cette petite
coco très gentil enfin me posais une
question d'argent mais sûrement pas
beaucoup d'argent
[Musique]
soyons clair une bonne fois pour toutes
si ce genre d'émission invité à stand-up
un réalisateur un comédien ce que vous
voulez quelqu'un de la télévision wral
la promo de ce qu'il veut on s'en fout
personne ne lui posera la question de
combien ils gagnent personnes on va dire
alors est ce que ça t'a plu de bosser
sur ce film alors c'est quoi ce nouveau
projet d'émission on peut voir un
extrait alors je comprends que c'est
tellement nouveau pour les gens que du
coup il faut un référentiel mais à un
moment il faut être plus curieux que ça
si on continue à faire des vidéos tous
les jours année après année et à faire
des projets c'est que oui on envie vous
sentez que je suis un petit peu
échauffés désolé on va regarder un
dernier truc voilà c'est comme ça au
moins c'est bouclé on revient en 2014
c'est sur tf1 l'émission sept à huit
présenté par harry roselmack caméra
m'ont suivi quelques temps même pas une
journée je pense dès le lancement de
l'émission wasl je réalise à j'ai fait
wow d'ivoire et vous allez découvrir
derrière l'humoriste un peu potache à
vrai businessman du web
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que le lancement a été
écrit avant même de tourner le reportage
parce qu'en fait je parle pas de
business ou cocteau soit vous allez voir
des réunions d'écriture ce genre de
choses donc même si le reportage il dit
autre chose
vous allez voir un business man du web
vous cyprien iov à 24 ans si vous ne
connaissez pas au casting et que vous
avez ratées la tendance des ados à la
quelques secondes dans le métro parisien
il est reconnu par tous les passagers de
moins de 20 ans alors oui c'est très
gentil il adore ce que je fais pourquoi
filmer le métro ça ne sert à rien mais
en fait il voulait des images de gens
qui me reconnaissent ils se sont dit
tiens on va dans le métro voilà il ya
des grosses caméras et du cou et les
gens qui disent [ __ ] mais c'est quoi
ces grosses caméras et il dit quelque
chose lui tiens je vais demander une
photo est en fait du coup ils ont eu
exactement ce qu'il voulait pour
illustrer leurs reportages montrer que
des gens me reconnaissent dans la rue je
trouve que c'est une mise en scène très
marrant et moi j'ai l'impression d'être
une bile star hollywoodienne dans un
café du quartier latin cyprien trahi par
son proche un sketch il n'a jamais pris
de cours de comédie ni de théâtre
contrairement à son compère julien
josselin
oui je suis et humoriste sur internet
mais ne connaît pas le même succès elle
semble une parodie des réunions
marketing des multinationales chez les
cats génial on écrivait les réunions ça
ça c'est mon vrai quotidien c'est pas
être un businessman du web comme il
prétendra en tout cas je pense passer
des réunions d'écriture essaie de
trouver des idées travail et de la
préparation des tournages du montage et
de l'écriture
et c'est génial de revoir ces images là
parce que voilà on écrivait ce sketch
qui pour moi est très culte dans ma vie
mais ce j'adorais bossé là dessus
aujourd'hui ouvre réaliste grand style
des vidéos humoristiques
il en a fait son métier par la
monétisation de ses 54 vidéo ils
gagneraient entre cinq et dix mille
euros chaque mois je peux en vivre comme
ça c'est sûr l'indépendance pour moi
c'est déjà exceptionnel cherche pas à
être riches en faisant ça juste être
indépendant et faire ce qui me plaît sur
internet impossible d'en savoir plus
impossible d'en savoir plus pourtant
nous n aurons vraiment à voir sa fiche
de paye ainsi que sa fiche d'imposition
on n'y échappe pas j'ai toujours la même
réponse
encore aujourd'hui si je dois répondre
je dirais je suis content d'être
indépendant ne fait pas ce métier pour
l'argent c'est débile fait ça parce que
c'est une opportunité de créer de
proposer du contenu à des gens qui sont
loin de vous c'est ça c'est formidable
si tu t'en réussit tant mieux ça te
permet d'investir dans d'autres choses
c'est ça c'est ça être tube heures pour
moi voilà merci la télévision pour ces
grands moments de rire mais également un
peu d'énervement je comprends tous ceux
qui bossent à la télé qui essaient de
faire des reportages des petits sujets
et on leur dit vas-y mais moi une ligne
sur les youtuber mais c'est quoi je sais
pas il gratte hop il assimile abonnés
12000 et ils sont à côté de la plaque
comprend un petit peu le processus
moi je souhaite qu'ils aient de plus en
plus de gens qui prennent ça quand même
au sérieux et il ya plein d'émissions
qui sont vraiment superbes vues
quotidien qui parlait dé youtuber
c'était intéressant j'ai participé à
l'émission le tube qui était c'était
vraiment mortel ça parler du fond il
connaissait le sujet le 19 45 de m6
aussi qui voit là à parler des actions
de youtube heures sur l'écologie sur
tout ça en soit vous pouvez vous
demander combien on gagne mais arrêter
de poser là
sont systématiquement si pour les
journalistes la seule question qui
veulent savoir à mon propos un autre
propos c'est combien on gagne ça n'en
vaut pas la peine je pense qu'il ya
plein d'autres choses beaucoup plus
intéressante à creuser
soyons positifs peut-être qu'on aura des
émissions intéressantes au sujet du tube
heures et du jeu vidéo et tout ça moi je
dis bientôt 13000 abonnés voilà
n'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo
peut-être qu'on sera voilà 13 min loup
14001 jour je ne sais pas road to 13000
abonnés je compte sur vous
[Musique]